well I hope that my work and the work of
my colleagues helps people to understand
that dolphins are sentient beings with
lives to lead and I think that it's time
to sort of think about dolphins and
other animals in a way that shifts our
perspective away from viewing them as
objects and commodities to actual beings
with lives to lead everything we know
about dolphins and their intelligence
their social lives their cultural lives
their emotionality their self-awareness
tells us that these are beings on a par
with humans in terms of their ability to
suffer and given that I've given the
fact that our species tends to say that
we love dolphins the way we treat them
is really quite appalling so the way we
treat them and how we claim we feel
about them are totally at odds and I
hope that my research helps people to
understand who they are and perhaps come
to realize that we shouldn't be treating
them as objects but rather a sentient
beings
you